people on Reddit kept asking me about
some guy named Boris apparently you
coached him at henzo's and he was a
legend and uh he was terrifyingly good
uh What made him a legend who's this
Boris character uh Boris is one of my
early students when I think he was
either my first or second black belt
Boris came from Long Island he was a
wrestler he was a Russian Jewish descent
and uh highly intelligent yeah and um
now he was short of stature but very
powerfully built in compact
um
uh very
nice polite young man
um but also slightly eccentric which I
always liked about him
um
he would always come dressed with
glasses on and he would leave the gym
uh dressed like to use the American
phrase a complete nerd with like his
pocket protector and any now he was
heavily muscled but he would dress in
such way that it didn't appear so when
he left and we always used to laugh like
you imagine some guy tried to mug as far
as they would see him with his with his
nerdy glasses on his pocket protector
and they would literally run into like
one of the most formidable human beings
in the entire New York area Boris
started training Jiu-Jitsu I believe in
Long Island and then
um when he got a tech job in Manhattan
started training with us in a morning
class now these were relatively early
days in Manhattan and my teaching career
and uh he and a group of others a very
small group used to train early in the
morning around 6am
before work and
Boris was a legend in those days now a
very young George Saint Pierre
came to
train with us at that time and he would
come in at 6 a.m to do his morning class
and he was one of the main training
partners for for Boris and um Boris
being arrested I used to generally
prefer top possession and I would always
encourage George to play bottom position
actually you've got to get a good and
bottom position you never know I know
you're good at takedowns but one day
someone's going to put you down so
you've got to work bottom position
um and borrows a very strong guard
passing I remember one of George's
happiest days is finally after like two
years one day he uh swept Boris got on
top and finished them and I remembered
he was that was one of his biggest uh uh
throws in all of uh his his training
career was the last time that ever
happened
no Boris was uh he was a very formal man
for that time the funny thing about
Boris is uh every time we would have a
conversation he would say I'm only going
to do the sport until I'm 40 years old
and then I'm going to stop
and I was like why like why not be like
a lifelong martial artist you know you
got so good you're good at you did so
you've got great skills you've worked
hard why not just keep going it's like
it's ridiculous for a man to train after
40 there's no need
and you can never give any reason for
this just it was just ridiculous so one
day he you know this is a guy who came
in literally every day
6 a.m every day
one day he comes in he comes up to be at
the industry and goes hey John I just
turned 40. so I won't be seeing you
again
and I thought that he's joking so I'm
like I'll see you tomorrow Boris he's
like no you won't and walks off
how gangster is that and then he never
came back I've never seen borrow since
he came in was one of the best crappers
I ever saw and just
that's it buddy I'm out and um so
there's no one to walk away yeah